but truly we're all connected we're all
brothers and sisters every every one of
us not just humans but animals we're all
about the extraterrestrials it's the
same there's not there's not a big
difference between like I know that
sounds super crazy because oh my gosh
now we're talking about ETS but the soul
has many different opportunities to
Incarnate not just human not just Earth
okay Earth is Earth is precious it's
very unique I I was able to feel and
know the incredible unique preciousness
of Earth but it's not the only show in
town it's not the only class you can go
to it's not the only place there's other
systems with incredibly different
vibrations not just in our entire
universe but there are entire other
universes available we're us we're you
and you're you and I'm I mean that's
what we are we're just playing human do
you think that we'll have confirmation
of extraterrestrials on Earth or is that
yeah I think it's inevitable yeah